[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on june the 30th 2022
my name is freddie gray i am the deputy
editor of the spectator
and i will be your host today
on the show this week we'll be talking
about the spectator's cover piece
which is the cold war this is a
reference to the fact that germany might
be coming up for a very very cold winter
if vladimir putin turns off the gas taps
i'll be joined by wolfgang munchow
and gideon rackman
next we'll talk about politics with
james forsythe and katie balls boris
johnson has been jetting about the world
desperately trying to escape his
domestic troubles has he had any luck
and then we'll be moving to america
where we'll be talking about the supreme
court's decision to overturn roe versus
wade a lot of democrats are up in arms
about the decision but do they really
want to change the law in order to
protect abortion rights i'll be talking
to kate andrews about her piece in this
week's magazine
changing tack we'll look at
cryptocurrency which uh only a year ago
seemed like one of the greatest
investments ever and now looks like a
bit of a disaster
jamie bartlett has done a podcast a very
successful podcast called the missing
crypto queen
about an enormous financial scam
involving something called onecoin
i'll be talking to him about the scam
and about cryptocurrency generally
and finally why do people like going to
watch septuagenarian and octogenarian
rockstars strut about on stage
i'll be talking to rachel johnson
about the phenomenon of very very old
bands performing very very old songs for
middle-aged people
but before we start with all that i
would like to encourage you to take out
a subscription to the spectator we have
a fantastic offer at the moment for just
one pound a week you can have full
digital that's online and app access to
all of the spectators content
and if you want the print magazine and i
think you should want the print magazine
you only have to pay a pound extra on
top of that
go to www.spectator
dot co dot uk forward slash tv offer to
get that
and while you're at it why not subscribe
to the spectator's brilliant youtube
channel simply click the red button at
the bottom of the screen and the bell
icon to make sure you never ever miss an
episode
when in late february
russia invaded the ukraine
a lot of commentators were struck by how
strongly germany responded against
russia and for ukraine
but we're now 126 days into the war and
the international dynamics are changing
a big concern as wolfgang mounchow
expresses in his cover piece for the
spectator this week
is that germany is going to face a very
cold winter simply because vladimir
putin still holds
enormous power over the country because
of his control of gas and energy
i'm joined now by wolfgang who i should
say is director of euro intelligence
and gideon rachman of the financial
times who is also author of a new book
the age of the strong man
wolfgang i'll start with you how worried
is germany uh about whether
its support for ukraine can survive uh
what could be a cold winter
well they're
at the moment more worried about the
cold winter than than their support for
ukraine uh what what is happening is
that that putin that the russians have
cut the gas throughput to the pipeline
system by about 50 percent
and that means that the germany west as
germany goes into the winter
the gas storage tanks will not be full
they will be half filled they're about
50 filled right now
and the plan had been to fill them up to
about 100 or 90 percent and then that
would be enough for them to
uh to get through the winter with the
normal gas flows resuming the fear is
that when russia reduced those volumes
that this was the beginning of what
might be a russian gas embargo that
russia might might decide to cut the
volumes now and to either continue
to supply and reduce volumes which is
which would be enough for germany to
have a
an energy crisis or actually to cut the
volumes altogether
and then there would be no plan b
germany does not have
uh alternative gas supplies in the short
term
uh there would be uh there are over two
or three year periods they can probably
do this uh there there have been talks
with the qataris uh but but these
the there is no capacity uh in qatar for
uh for for further sales to germany the
americans want to supply more more
liquid gas liquid natural gas
uh and they will uh but it will not be
enough to make up these enormous
shortfalls that would would result from
a nation from a russian embargo now
putin has in the past not used gas as a
as a geopolitical weapon uh north stream
2 was sort of a long-term strategic
thing for him but it wasn't he never
used gas or at least in respect of
germany he didn't use gas he didn't cut
the gas in order to to change uh you
know to
for political for political reasons but
this is different because the germans
have already said they're going to get
out of russian gas anyway as part of the
eu
eu strategy so you know jump you know
he's not going to help them get this you
know smooth smooth smooth out of this
out of their russian contracts so he may
well be he may well have an incentive to
do this and the result if he did would
be a very significant energy crisis uh
in germany and the german economics
minister has warned about a lehman style
uh uh
event a contagious event of people you
know of gas companies and energy
companies failing and causing a ripple
of uh bankruptcies throughout the energy
sector
and of course uh that that reference to
layman's does hint that it might not
just be germany it could be uh could
create a global problem because uh
although obviously it'd be terribly bad
if german homes can't be heated there's
also the issue of german manufacturing
needed to be powered
it would it would have global impact but
it would certainly be european
uh it would certainly be european uh
economic shock uh the economic impact
assessments are very different economies
have come as often in these cases
different results but the credible ones
that i've been looking at look talk
about a recession to the tune of minus
five to minus seven percent of gdp
that's a lot
if you have these if you have these sort
of contagion effects
um
there could be this could this could
ripple through europe
the other thing that that we have the
other problem that we have
is that if if putin cuts the gas to
germany what you know will germany still
supply gas to other eu countries
or you know as they do now because
and is there a solidarity i mean i was
talking about the solidarity with
ukraine in the article but i was all you
know there's another factor of the
solidarity between eu members
uh will there be enough eu solidarity to
share the gas that they have or will it
be you know it arrives in my country
first and we'll use it up and you know
if if you don't have it that's your bad
luck so we have to see about this
but it's not exactly a a you know a
solidarity test that people would
probably relish at this point
gideon i'll bring you in um
donald trump uh one of the strong men in
your book uh was much mocked um
when he said things like uh
germany is totally controlled by russia
however
as we've gone forwards in time uh it
seems like trump had a pretty good point
wouldn't you say well totally controlled
i think was probably overstating it i
mean as you've seen by the strength of
the german reaction to what russia has
done in ukraine in fact they've changed
their foreign policy
uh really pretty significantly but i
think trump had a point that germany
had over many years unwisely allowed
itself to become
very very reliant on russian gas uh they
didn't really believe that russia would
ever use this weapon
you heard for example that even
throughout the cold war during crises
russia always continued to supply
germany with gas but now germany itself
along with the european union has
decided that this dependency is too
dangerous
uh and that they're going to wean
themselves off you know a senior german
official said to me a few weeks ago that
putin before the war was looking at 30
years of stable oil and gas revenues uh
from europe and now he's looking at
three years but those three years could
be very bumpy for the reasons that
wolfgang lays out that it's you know
there's it you can't just find new
sources of gas that easily um all the
places they're looking for will either
take time to develop or already
committed so yeah they could have a very
rough winter but from um
you know putin's point of view i could
see why it would be very tempting to do
this pure anger apart from anything else
but there's only one way i think it
works for him strategically is if it
really destabilizes germany so much
that you get a rise of radical parties
such as the afd that are much more
sympathetic to russia and really change
german foreign policy that's one
possible outcome but i think it's just
as likely that it hardens german and
european views that russia is a danger
and we're locked into a long-term
conflict with them so i'm not sure it's
a wise policy for putin to pursue but
then invading ukraine is probably not a
wise policy
so you don't think there's uh do you
think there is a chance that he'd do
this because it would seem to be
further economic suicide from putin to
uh actually force european countries
who've talked about moving away from gas
for a long time but not actually done it
to move away to alternative sources of
energy yeah i mean who knows but um you
know we've all kind of go a lot of
people have got what was in his head
wrong
uh he may just be waving the weapon in
in the hope that this will force or
persuade the europeans to put more
pressure on ukraine to
uh to come to the negotiating table
but i suppose you could also argue from
the russian point of view in a sense
they've already inflicted this strategic
loss on themselves they know that uh if
the europeans are as good as their word
and can follow through that the russian
sales of gas to europe will end in about
three to five years and that's a big
problem for them because they don't have
the pipeline capacity yet to redirect it
to china and as we saw with nordstrom 2
constructing these new pipelines takes
many many years so maybe it's a sort of
scenario where he says well you've
damaged us we're going to try and damage
you but um
you know i i just don't know i mean
putin will have thought it through
probably quite carefully it's
interesting talking to sort of senior
executives of the oil and gas
multinationals who say that talking to
putin was like talking to one of their
peers he had an incredible command of
the oil and gas industry and russian
economics but obviously the bigger
picture for him is geopolitical and uh
he doesn't have that many good options
to be honest i you know
as you were saying russia is doing a bit
better in the war now but if you look at
their strategic
overall picture you know if this war was
about nato enlargement well sweden and
and finland have just you know been
agreed to join nato so nato has had its
biggest enlargement for a very long time
and um obviously the russian economy is
shrinking they've taken big losses on
the battlefield so
uh he's got a few
tactics he can use but strategically i
think he's in a bad spot
wolfgang you touched on nuclear power
the greens are in germany's governing
coalition now and they do not want to
stop the commitment to to
eliminating nuclear power
and presumably they do not want to go
back to coal
as a source of german energy
how much are environmental concerns
getting in the way of dealing with what
is a a serious looming emergency in the
energy sector
right thank you for the question i'm
going to answer it in a in a few seconds
but let me just make one additional
comment to
what what gideon says and i think his is
his analysis is right that putin doesn't
have uh you know put in putin's you know
putin may be over very much over playing
his hand but we we have to consider two
factors here first of all he got himself
an awful lot of money
through the rise in oil and gas prices i
i you know i've sort of been doing the
maths on what his likely current account
surplus is likely to be this year and
we're looking at 200 to 250 billion euro
dollars
and that's almost as much as the money
we throw as the assets the west have
frozen
this is a huge amount of money and the
the gas sales are still very profitable
for him especially now that the gas
prices are rising as a result of his
decision to cut the throughput uh he
will make more money by selling less
cars that is quite a possible possible
thing but he is in a position to afford
it uh he is not you know he his problem
is spending the cash it's not getting it
um and the in the medium term strategic
option
uh is very much to to supply
uh uh the the
the parts of the world that are not the
west you know africa india china
uh he's got a you know there are a
number of countries that would still buy
russian products and that might also
supply russia with electrical components
the one that he is really not getting
from the west
asking about
getting back to your question on the
nuclear on the nuclear power for the
greens i mean if you sort of you're
sitting here in the uk and if you you
know you would you wouldn't think twice
about this because nuclear power seems
to be you know these are the
german nuclear power stations are some
of the safest in the world they're built
of the highest standards
there's nothing wrong with us the power
stations that are being that are being
decommissioned now they're still that
the three are still running and supply
about six percent of the electricity
with all this stuff happening you would
probably not want to have another you
know shortfall of electricity on top of
the gas situation so it would be a
rational almost a no-brainer
however if you know if you understand
the history of the green party it was
their opposition to nuclear power
that uh you know that got them into
politics uh this is the the this is sort
of as
principled and and as as difficult for
them an issue as like you know europe
was for the conservative party it's not
something that they can easily just dump
and say okay well we'll do it and you
know it's it's because it's rational and
robert harbeck clearly you know
i don't think he would have a strong
personal view on this matter and as an
economics minister he's probably
you know he knows the he knows the
numbers and he will probably say fine we
will do this but as a politician he
would struggle to to do this unless he
he had no other choice so the what i
think is going to happen is they will
definitely not discuss this at the
moment but should putin cut the gas and
should there be a mayhem and you know
and
he might just ask his party you know
shall we keep the nuclear power stations
running for another three years or shall
we start commissioning coal what do you
think
i think he might just get away with the
with the prolongation of the of the
power station i actually would go
further because there have been three
stations cut at the end of last year
that can still be recommissioned as
possible technically
there are legal obstacles as you know in
germany everything is always legal
obstacles but technically they could
actually get 12 to 13 percent of
electricity
uh back online and that's quite a lot uh
that to me would have been the the most
logical
uh uh emergency plan to to fix a a a you
know clear and present danger because
ten percent is a lot of a lot of energy
uh that you would have to replace in a
in a in a period when gas
uh and oil and coal is
hugely expensive so you know these these
discussions will be how i'm i'm told the
three
the three nuclear
stations from from last year will stay
shut because nobody has the appetite to
go through a protracted legal battle but
i would still think that the ones that
are still operational today
uh that those are possibly still in play
despite of what you what you're hearing
officially
gideon your book is about how strong men
such as putin uh are
increasingly sort of defined global
politics in the 21st century and when
you look at this relationship between
russia and germany does it not suggest
that strong men leaders
have advantages
in a time of rising geo-strategic
tensions
they have advantages over
democratically elected people and
more democratically elected people and
the pressures they face at home well
we'll see i mean you know i would
in my book i've been often being accused
of being excessively gloomy but i think
that
you know arguably what putin has done in
ukraine actually reveals the weakness of
a strong man-style system because
there was nobody to say to him look this
is crazy or you've got to get through
this this through parliament uh
things were so centralized around him
that he was able to take a decision that
even his own foreign minister apparently
didn't really know about until the day
before
um so
and it looks like for the reasons i set
out that it will be a big
strategic uh setback for russia that's
putting mildly not to speak of the kind
of economic and political cultural
aspects of it so i think
you know
yes he has more he has the ability to
make rapid decisions to maneuver quickly
in this situation but he also has the
ability to inflict a disaster on his
country which i think he's done
and by contrast i mean i think that
although clearly uh you know you can
point at all these arguments about
nuclear power and say for god's sake
this is ridiculous we should be able to
move quicker actually i think that the
democratic countries of the west move
pretty fast uh
you know in imposing now six packages of
sanctions uh these are you know 27 eu
countries the uk the us canada japan
australia south korea all came together
um and
slightly confounded the image of this
sort of slow moving democratic west that
was unable to get its act together
wolfgang and gideon we'll end it there
but thank you very much indeed for
coming on
let's move on to the week in politics
boris johnson has just returned from an
eight-day tour of the world where he has
been stopping at various conferences and
coming up with various proposals along
with other world leaders one upshot of
all this is that the uk has now
committed an additional 1 billion
to give to ukraine's war chest
i'm joined now by james forsyth and
katie balls to talk about this
james it's quite obvious that boris is
more comfortable on the foreign front
than the domestic front uh has it been a
reasonably successful week for him
yeah he's reached that stage in his
premiership where these foreign summits
and meetings were uh are a kind of
blessed relief from the toil and
difficulties of domestic politics and
you could you could see that he was
enjoying himself in a way that he hasn't
been domestically uh with all the
difficulties with the leadership and the
like uh on the world stage he also had
uh at the um g7 summit and at the nato
meeting he had an argument to make about
uh how the west has a responsibility to
ensure that ukraine goes into any
negotiations with russia in the
strongest possible position
and i think that you one i mean there
was a worry
in whitehall before these uh g7 and nato
summits that some of that striking
alliance unity you had at the beginning
of this conflict was beginning to fray
with people beginning to worry about
what was going to happen this winter
and in the end there was i think
more unanimity and more agreement about
the need to
bolster the weaponry being sent to
ukraine to ensure to ensure that any
peace is made on terms that the
ukrainians are happy with that than had
been expected beforehand and i think you
know and i think that i mean the
alliance
that sense i think will lead to probably
a step up in the amount of military
equipment being sent to ukraine whether
that will be enough to to turn the tide
of the fighting in the east kind of
remains to be seen i thought the other
striking thing about the nato summit was
the the move in terms of just how
significant uh the nato
change and approach on its eastern
border is previously nato relied on
these kind of tripwire forces it is now
going to have a much more substantial
presence there a kind of presence that
was designed to be able to hold talking
of russian advance i also think you can
see in all the references to china in
this new nato strategic concept
and the fact that japan and south korea
and australia were invited to the summit
you know where this debate goes next
because however um brutal the russian
war in ukraine is you know in terms of
the great power competition of this
century the most significant great power
competition is going to be between the
u.s and its allies and china for the
question of who dominates the 21st
century do you think democracies versus
autocracies is going to be the the theme
of the the coming months
i i think what kind of world we live in
and i think obviously that there is a
there is there is a flash point there in
taiwan which you know i i personally am
a subscriber to the theory advanced by
the american uh strategist and academic
hal brands so you know but that the the
u.s china competition is going to be the
most intense in the next decade um in
that ultimately uh china is a peaking
power and i think 10 years from now it
will be clear that it is caught in the
middle income trap it is going to be a
less significant force than it looks so
it has this decade to try and change the
facts on the ground and i think that
makes a an assault on taiwan within the
next 10 years um highly likely and that
is obviously going to be an even more
disruptive event uh both uh uh in
military times and economically than
russia's invasion of ukraine i thought
you were making a peaking
pun there but uh i don't you wouldn't be
so so gauche as to to use such an
old-fashioned name uh katie moving up to
you um
there is despite all the commitment uh
towards nato from various statesmen
uh there is this odd story or this sort
of suggestion of some discontent within
government about britain's commitment to
nato because ben wallace seems to be
pushing for more
and the government seems to be pushing
for slightly less what's going on there
yes so this week it emerged the
government has dropped one of its
manifesto pledges which is effectively
to rise defense spending with inflation
or keep them in line now of course this
is in the face of soaring inflation and
but it still caused some unrest if you
think about the current situation in
ukraine the fact that lots of tory mps
believes that this shows you should be
investing more not less
and there is uh some private letters
that somehow reports have emerged
publicly between ben wallace and others
now the defense secretary has tried to
play down the row but has said that he
is happy with spending for now
um but effectively from 2024 and he
thinks there should be more defense
spending now that is around the time
that you would expect despite some of
the rumors of early elections the
government to be looking for re-election
the tory party to be going to the polls
and therefore
i think we're seeing
a situation where people talking about
you know what probably i imagine being a
manifested pledge of more spending at
the next election um now i think that
there are two things here one is that
the government is developing a
reputation for dropping its manifesto
commitments and of course they will say
well we've had a very difficult time of
a pandemic and others but it's quite a
long list now if you go through it and
then secondly i think because boris
johnson's position is unstable and
despite the fact he has been you know
living up on the world stage in recent
days and looks comfortable doing so he
still has many domestic problems at home
lots of uncertainty adapt and doubt
right now amongst his own ministers
about whether he will lead them into the
next election and even if boris johnson
is still talking about a third term um i
think we're seeing that if we do end up
in a tory leadership contest before the
next election defense spending is going
to be a really key part of that
some people are suggesting that um
wallace who is
one of the favorites to replace boris
as prime minister
should boris go
may be sort of trying to maneuver
slightly here which would be odd
considering he's been
very much a as i understand it uh boris
johnson loyalist so far
yeah it's not it's not a pledge that's
going to do you badly amongst the
membership is it if you if you look like
you're the one who's asking for more um
defense spending and liz trust the
foreign secretary has made similar
soundings in the past few months and
it's the treasury uh i'm particularly
risky sooner i think they want to
differentiate from
with rishi sunak who was seen as a
leadership frontrunner a bit less so
since since the non-dom row as someone
who's saying actually we we need to have
some spending discipline right now i can
look at the general fiscal picture and i
think therefore you can read in all
these things because of boris johnson's
instability a sense that potential
candidates are showing a bit of leg now
i think a figure such as ben wallace is
loyal to the prime minister as much as a
minister is these days um but i think
the argument you hear some mps making
private leaders it's not disloyal to
think about what your leadership
campaign should be just in case the
prime minister doesn't make it and i
think since the confidence vote some of
these ministers believe they have a bit
of license to actually think about what
would happen in their benefit leadership
contest and given there is so much talk
about another no confidence vote before
the year is out
james uh the prime minister now returns
to domestic matters and it's looking
pretty brutal again for him uh the
privileges committee which a lot of the
rebels uh are quite excited about
in terms of really hurting him there's a
suggestion today that people in number
10 think it will be a kind of kangaroo
court
how bad do you think the privileges
committee is going to be for him
i think the privileges committee is the
biggest risk for him because if he is
found to have deliberately uh misled
parliament i mean you know that is
clearly game over that is the most you
know
that is a straight out resigning matter
under under the ministerial code and i
think in those circumstances there's no
doubt that the 1922 committee executive
would would change the rules i i think
that i think number 10 have to be very
careful
in terms of how they played this you
know they tried to put some pressure on
the committee not to appoint harriet
harman as the chair she was appointed as
a chair yesterday and i think as they
did with the super i think there is a
danger that you know you saw liz trust
today being very careful to distance
herself from those you know those
anonymous comments about it being a
kangaroo court saying that she trusted
the committee implicitly to do it to do
its job i i think the worry for boris
johnson is that
the thing you will have to explain to
clementi is why he did not correct the
record as quickly as possible because
you know
it is accepted under kind of
parliamentary rules sometimes ministers
and the prime minister will say things
that are inaccurate but they believe to
be accurate at the time that they say it
but what they are meant to do when they
realize that what they said was
inaccurate is correct the record
as quickly as possible that that clearly
didn't happen in this case and boris
johnson you know he can say that look he
didn't want to do this because he didn't
want to look like he was undermining or
pursue grey report or or or the police
inquiry but i think you will have to
explain that fact and that that is what
is i think is going to be most difficult
for him
james and katie thank you very much
indeed
now on friday in america the supreme
court overruled roe versus wade the
decision that had made abortion legal at
the federal level since
1973.
there's been a lot of uproar about it
all over the world
but as kate andrews says in her piece
today
the supreme court has not banned
abortion in america it has returned the
matter to the elected representatives
but kate as you suggest in your piece
america's elected representatives are
not terribly keen it seems to address
the matter
so this is the deep worry as you point
out there fred the supreme court has not
banned abortion it actually makes very
clear in the majority opinion that they
feel that this is simply not a decision
that should have ever been made at the
supreme court level and that is a
question for the legislatures whether
that be on the federal level the state
level it's a question for politicians if
they want to protect women's rights in
this way to pass some laws of course
congress hasn't done that and i think
part of the fear that you can sense in
america right now
it really stems from the fact that it's
not obvious at all that politicians want
to or are capable of coming to the table
to have a sensible conversation about
this because for decades now the supreme
court has acted as sort of a judicial
umbrella under which people could use
the topic of abortion and women's rights
to make a lot of political points to try
to gather votes around election times
never really thinking that they'd have
to act on whatever they were proposing
uh and so now we're in a very difficult
situation where we're very divided in
america uh you know it's it's very much
the democrats versus the republicans and
we have a midterm election coming up and
so you have everyone including joe biden
and kamala harris talking about how we
can solve this issue in the next
election and you should read that as
vote democrat or on the other side vote
republican and it really feels like
actually women's rights and trying to
talk about this now sensibly and come to
some kind of perhaps compromise on the
federal level is secondary to winning
votes
well is this part of the culture war
problem in america that's been going on
for decades now
and abortion is perhaps the the biggest
and longest running culture war fight
um that both political parties have got
so used to using these issues to to gin
up the base
and as a result they don't actually want
to
um resolve them because they are useful
mechanisms similar perhaps to to the
fight over gun rights and there was a
there was a
law was passed last week on gun rights
last week um but these are issues that
fire up the base but but politicians
don't actually want to resolve them
precisely because they fire up the base
i think that's exactly right it was very
grating frankly to see former president
barack obama tweeting out what a
devastating decision this was from the
supreme court encouraging people to
knock on doors and to vote to change it
when he of course had a super majority
when he came into the oval office in
2009 and he could have codified abortion
rights uh into law with his
supermajority and actually said at the
time that it wasn't a legislative
priority you know i'm pleased that the
democrats think this is a priority now
but as i write in the piece and maybe
this is wishful thinking on my part i'm
sure a lot of people will say i'm being
optimistic here but i really believe
that if women's rights and and the right
to access an abortion we're at the top
of people's uh priority list that right
now joe biden would be speaking to some
more of the liberal republicans
particularly suzanne collins the
republican senator from maine
and some of her colleagues who who
themselves are interested in a more
narrow but still defined scope to uh
legalize abortion at the federal level
to try to come up with some compromise
some solution i propose in the piece
maybe say a 12-week backstop in which
women across america have the right to
access abortion at up to 12 weeks and
then states could legislate further if
they want that will obviously upset a
lot of people on the pro-life side who
don't see any negotiation to be had it
will frustrate a lot of people in in the
pro-choice side who would see 12 weeks
as a big step backwards but
what i'm trying to get at is you know
biden needs 60 votes in the senate to
actually pass some serious legislation
on this and whilst i can't immediately
tally 60 i can get quite close looking
at some of the statements that were made
from republican senators after uh roe v
wade was overturned last week he should
at least be trying he should be trying
to negotiate this is after all how he
sold himself to the public moderate joe
it's reasons like people like me
voted for him in 2020 because i i did
think that when he promised unity he he
meant it to some some degree um but want
to be very clear there's there's really
ugly stuff coming out from the
republican side talk about how we need
to ban abortion at the federal level now
no state's choice in this at all about
how we need to criminalize the women and
doctors who do this
both sides almost dare i say seem to be
enjoying the political vitriol a bit too
much and what's happening in real time
is millions of women are losing access
to abortion in their state in
practically every circumstance so i
think if we wanted to do something that
was in in many ways a compromise but i
think also common sense given how
divided america still is on this issue
we joe biden and and the more liberal
republicans could be trying to get there
but um i just don't i don't see that
that progress trying to be made
do you think uh the democrats who
clearly think that uh this issue will
now help them uh change the narrative
ahead of the midterms uh and as we said
earlier fire up the base do you think
they might be overreading um the
situation and perhaps not realizing that
the broad uh slaves of american opinion
is not really in line uh with where most
democrats are at least publicly on this
issue which is
pretty hardcore on the pretty hardcore
end of the pro church position i mean it
wasn't so long ago that democrats joe
biden even would say
that abortion should be safe legal and
rare which is
generally thought to be polls would
suggest
the consensus position in america
so the majority of americans do support
the right that to access abortion and
it's around 67 so close to 70 percent of
americans support it in that first
trimester which is why i mention up to
12 weeks in my piece as you point out
freddie the democrats did bring
legislation to the floor in may
claiming that they were trying to codify
abortion rights into law but in my
opinion it was a stun designed to fail
because if you look at what was in that
legislation it was very radical it
essentially created loopholes so you
could access abortion throughout your
full nine months of pregnancy
and that was never ever going to garner
republican support it actually lost a
few democrats as it was going through i
think that was designed to be able to
say in the midterms look we tried to do
this you need to give us more votes you
need to give us a super majority so that
we can codify abortion laws but you know
i think a lot of voters will see through
that as you say the majority of
americans are
pretty confident on where they stand on
the issue and it is a
liberal a classically liberal leaning
towards a woman's right to choose but it
isn't extreme
and i think a lot of the support for the
democrats around roe may already be
baked into some of the polling i've no
doubt it's going to help them in the
midterms but what i'm deeply worried
about um is that this may be the last
chance for a genuine bipartisan
compromise for quite a while because if
the democrats miscalculate this and the
republicans do take the house and
possibly the senate then you have
complete gridlock chances of compromise
are near zero and we're in the situation
we're in now which which is one i don't
like as somebody who supports the
women's right to choose and which as i
said millions
of women across various states are
losing access to abortion in their state
in almost every circumstance so i think
now is the time the democrats have
majorities in the house and the senate
but they're slim and they're republicans
who seem like they might be willing to
talk about this this is the moment to
come up with something that isn't too
extreme at either end
and i'm also worried about something
rather extreme coming in on either end
full stop even if even if joe biden were
say to get his super majority if they
pass legislation around such a
contentious issue like abortion and very
emotive issue that seems really partisan
then the chances that it's going to be
overturned by the republicans when they
get in and the other party always gets
in eventually is significantly higher
you know i envy european countries
looking at the fact that they have
already gone through that democratic
process and that public debate around
women's rights and have more or less
settled the issue america because of roe
v wade um really didn't do that it
actually decided to use it as a as an
election point as we've spoken about and
we never had a serious grown-up
conversation between the two sides so
we're like 50 years behind in this
conversation and we're having to have it
now and i fear that our politicians are
simply not up to doing so
do you ever think that perhaps in
britain and european countries uh as you
suggest that the question has been
settled politically
uh but perhaps again the political
classes are slightly out of touch with
the public for instance uh danny kruger
the tory mp yesterday in parliament uh
advanced what sounded to me anyway like
a
rather mild pro-life case and said this
is a should be a subject for debate and
it's not for us to lecture americans
about it and he's been widely slammed
for having said that
um which suggests that the the appetite
for debate in britain it's not that it's
just settled that's that there isn't any
willingness to have the debate i
listened to danny kruger's comments in
full and while i'm not sure i agreed
with everything that he said coming from
a more pro-choice perspective i i didn't
find his comments insulting her in any
way dangerous as i think a lot of people
have tried to suggest i think the heat
around his comments comes from the fact
that roe v wade has just been overturned
and there has been this uncomfortable
thing happening here in the uk where
some commentators and politicians have
wanted to suggest that what's just
happened in america is now coming for
the uk and i don't think there's any
evidence to suggest that so when
somebody like krueger stands up and
gives anybody not it's not ammo but
gives them what they think might in some
circumstances be a little bit of ammo
they try to use it um and and so to your
point fred i
i think
his wider comments were about the fact
that here in the uk we can discuss
abortion and people don't com you know
people don't become enraged usually
people don't become
deeply angry and they don't make
horrible accusations immediately whereas
in the states um it is really difficult
under almost any circumstance to have a
public conversation about abortion that
isn't very very ugly uh and i think
that's the point he was trying to make
and i think has just been convenient for
some people to take that out of context
kate i'm going to cut you off there
because we're in danger of having a
reasonable conversation
thanks for having me fred
now as anybody who has had any interest
in the world of cryptocurrency knows um
it's a place that is full of scams
ponzi schemes swindlers and scanners
and perhaps the best example
of this is the story of onecoin and its
founder ruja
ignatova
jamie bartlett who joins us now is the
maker of a brilliant podcast called the
missing crypto queen which is now a
brilliant book
jamie for our listeners and viewers who
don't uh
know the story can you give us a little
bit of an outline of this rather
extraordinary and quite sad tale
yeah the the thanks for thanks for
having me the really quick version of
this is in in 2014 so quite a while ago
now this woman dr rouger ignatova
bulgarian german she comes out of
nowhere and basically tells the world
you've heard about bitcoin
lots of people making lots of money it's
going to change global finance forever
i've got a new one it's better it's
easier it's simpler it's called one coin
and within 18 months about a million
people from 175 countries had invested
close to sort of three to four billion
euros into this thinking they'd bought
the next
bitcoin
the value of their coins was going up
they were logging on checking them
they've spent all of their money on it
but they could never turn those coins
back into real money
and then in october 2017 dr ruja takes a
ryanair flight
from sofia bulgaria to athens greece and
disappears into thin air and all the
money's gone
and um she is still on the run and the
whole thing was a brilliantly designed
pyramid scheme essentially with a
cryptocurrency branding on top of it
well for my sims i've i've had some
experience of uh crypto pyramid schemes
and one could be forgiven for thinking
that the whole cryptocurrency world is
itself
uh a ponzi scheme at times
did you do you feel that that there's a
legitimate world of crypto still
yeah i do actually i think there's
there's different there's a difference
between something like bitcoin which
yeah it's highly speculative it's a
risky investment it goes up and it goes
down
but there is something interesting about
the idea of digital fixed supply
currency that operates outside
governments and central banks that's
sort of secured by mathematics the
problem is running alongside that is a
load of chances and scammers who think
oh no one really understands this
technology i'll pretend i've made the
next one and investors who are desperate
to
get a thousand percent return on their
investment are pouring their money into
those scam ones as well and it's very
very hard for an ordinary person to tell
the difference from one to the other
because they look kind of
indistinguishable in many ways one coin
was a bit different because it was
really a straight-up pyramid scheme i
mean it was sold in a pyramid fashion
you would buy the coins and then you'd
recruit people to buy coins who'd then
recruit people to buy coins and you'd
get commissions from every cell that you
made so it really was designed like a
pyramid scheme so it's slightly
different from
bitcoin it didn't really ever have any
technology behind it and bitcoin does
but it's the weird thing it's a kind of
gray zone between the legitimate ones
and the illegitimate ones a lot of them
look the same there's shades of grey for
all of them one coin just happens to be
a kind of outlier as it's just an out
and out scam
something that comes out uh in the
missing crypto queen is uh
the sort of cult-like nature of it and
you see this a lot in crypto land crypto
world
uh where people develop a sort of
religious faith
in the coin they invest in um and it's
almost a sort of prosperity gospel thing
if you believe in it hard enough you
will make money yeah which which is
which makes sense as well because in a
way it can become a bit self-fulfilling
because if everyone does believe in a
pyramid scheme the pyramid can keep
going for a very very long time so no no
one's incentivized to blow the whistle
on it because they all want to they all
want the the jamboree to carry on but
with one coin they they really did sort
of raise up the founder dr rouger
ignaciva as this godlike figure this
genius an incredible founder who's gonna
not only revolutionize global finance
but also make you personally rich and
once you've put your money into it
you're kind of so invested not only
financially but emotionally that you buy
into all of this stuff as well onecoin
even had a kind of a little hand gesture
that they'd go to they go to sort of
stadiums and arenas full of thousands of
screaming onecoin fans and make this
hand sign at each other you know we're
part of the club we're one coin is
although obviously that was ultimately
the value of the coin zero
so it was kind of lost on them all but
yeah they cultivated it but there is
there is something deeper about pyramid
schemes that it can become
self-fulfilling for a while and if
you're in at the top early
you can actually make money from these
things
and what is the latest on rudra do is is
there any chance of her being called
well i mean if you read my book you'll
find out that we've made quite a lot of
developments actually in in what
happened to her after she disappeared
and where we think she is
but alongside the things that we've
tried to discover
uh the authorities are finally sort of
closing in on this it's like six seven
years too late they should have been
doing this in 2015 and the annoying
thing about slow regulation in a world
of fast-moving tech is that it takes 18
months for a million people to invest
their money and if you're going to then
clamp down on it five years later it's
too late the money's tied up all around
the world in these sort of offshore
accounts and so on
but
just a month ago europol finally put dr
ruja on their most wanted list their
most wanted criminals list interpol
issued a red notice the german
government started ask started putting
up billboards and posters of rouge's
face saying have you seen this woman
five thousand euro reward for
information that could lead to her
arrest and they've apparently received a
load of tip-offs
uh but they have also said that
her and people with her are likely to be
armed so if you do see her fred don't go
you know just give me a call rather than
trying to apprehend her yourself i'll go
i'll go straight to you
please
before the authorities before interpol
uh
i i do wonder though i i thought your
podcast was brilliant and and i'm glad
it's had all the success it deserves but
do you not find it slightly weird that
a lot of the biggest hits sort of media
hits of the last few years have been
about scams i mean you think about
uh the fire festival documentary uh the
the blood one what was it called bad
blood
blood
dropped out
there's the tinder swindler which is a
bit late to the game that was got a lot
of interest
we seem to be obsessed with the way that
we can be ripped off through the
internet um presumably that's just
because a lot of people are being ripped
off through the internet
i totally agree with you i've been
thinking about this exact question that
we have become
a nation obsessed with true crime scam
stories i can't quite work out why it is
maybe you're right maybe it's because
partly
the majority of crime now takes place
online and then they're never re i mean
the police are so far behind this the
the prosecution rate for various online
fraud and online crime is negligible so
maybe we we try to make up for it by
watching these shows and
trying to figure out for ourselves
what's going on because we know the
police aren't going to help us but there
is a strange fascination not only with
um true crime but with women involved in
true crime because if you think about
theranos it was elizabeth elizabeth
holmes
uh inventing anna
was that other one the woman that said
yeah and and and obviously dr ruger as
well
something's going on and i i've got to
be honest i should i should know the
answer to that because it because i'm
part of the problem uh sort of
i suppose we worship we worship the rise
and the fall don't we and we we yeah we
we adore these people when that when the
scans working
uh and even when we know
it as well isn't there like oh look at
i'm not so stupid as to invested all my
money in a ponzi in a gigantic ponzi
scheme yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah
i wouldn't have invested in one coin
i've put all my money in dag coin
so so there is a strange fascination
with it and because it's everywhere but
never seemingly prosecuted it's like the
the podcasts and tv shows are doing
doing the job of the police of showing
these people finally getting their
comeuppance uh jamie are you working on
a another podcast to do with scams
hopefully
do you know what i kind of am but i'm
not allowed to tell you anything about
it the wisdom always yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but we're still working on the
missing crypto queen as well there's
going to be some new episodes coming out
soon because the story is still
unfolding and that's partly because a
million people are still hoping to get
their money back
and that can take a very very long time
when ponzi schemes collapse
well we better wrap it up there but um
many congratulations on the success of
the podcast and i'm sure the book
and thanks for coming on
thank you very much
right let's talk about viagra
hair dye and very very old rockers
last weekend was glastonbury and the
headline act
um on the friday was billy eilish who
was 20 years old
um but the rest of the weekend not just
at glastonbury but in hyde park was
dominated by aging rockers elton john
mick jagger paul mccartney
rachel johnson was in uh hyde park on
saturday night rachel johnson who is the
oldies pop culture critic
um rachel
why is britain so enthralled to
just going to concerts performed by very
very old people
i might point out that um i did back to
back i did elton john surelton on friday
night
and the following night the saturday
night i was in hyde park for two second
night running for the stones and then i
think there were a further
gaggle of aging rockers i think the
eagles played on sunday night so it's
been you know i'm not saying the summer
of love the summer of um viagra really
hasn't it because
it was
an astonishing experience to know that
my children i generation below me
were watching the youngest ever
headliner at glastonbury followed by the
oldest ever paul mccartney so billy
eilish was is 20 paul mccartney he's
just turned 80. then i was watching
mick jagger on stage aged 78 about to
turn 79 in july
and he had more energy i mean if you had
plugged skinny jagger into the national
grid he could have electrified the whole
show himself i've never seen so much
energy i don't know where it comes from
so
in a sense what i think mick jagger set
out to prove and proves is that when it
comes to rock and roll rock and roll
will never die
it's he had a kind of um
inveterate
energy and
and of somebody i don't know i haven't
seen many 28 year olds who could come
and command the stage with the with his
dancing and is
strutting and is prancing
so what i think he proved was
that age is just a number when it comes
to rock and roll but in the piece i've
written
for the spectator i point out that
however
uh
youthful that spirit is the flesh is
prey to mortal
uh you know a mortal cycle and
these rock dinosaurs have really
knocked it out of the park quite
literally this last weekend this summer
but you know the meteor the meteor is on
its way it hasn't struck but these guys
all started their shows and they talked
about like paul mccartney we saw george
harrison no longer with us john lennon
no longer with us and ditto charlie
watts was the whole thing opened with a
a montage of tribute to charlie what's
the drummer who who has died so you do
get the feeling that they are on the
there are they are knocking on heaven's
door sadly
well as you say in the piece they're the
only people that can really sort of
guarantee
massive ticket sales and the meteor is
coming um we hope they live as long as
possible uh but they can't go on forever
what's what's the rock industry what's
what's the live music industry going to
do
when it no longer has these bankable
geriatrics
well i mean
that is the question and it is the
question of all industries which is to
maintain the the um
the audience while replenishing it as
the headliners are aging i mean it's
it's been it is the perennial problem
but this is a bigger issue for rock and
roll than it is for other industries
because they don't make them like mick
jagger elton john anymore
these guys you know uh became big in the
60s 70s that's 60 years ago and
therefore they've got like about
catalogue that goes back 60 years how
are you going to find talent artists
that can fill pyramid stage or hyde park
for two and a half hours with 25 solid
gold bangers that is going to be the
challenge because festivals have grown
hugely in popularity partly because
the artists love them because they make
so much more money from live music than
they do from record sales now because of
streaming and spotify and all the rest
of it they only net about 10
of record sales but they can take home
about 90
of the gross ticket receipts when they
do an enormous gig like glasto
summertime ball
or um hyde park british summer time
it's it's often been said that one of
the problems with with kind of pop
culture is that the boomers and i'm not
saying for a moment that you're a boomer
you're so much younger than that uh but
the boomers can't let the youth have
their culture and the boomers have to
have youth culture for themselves and so
therefore they're not really letting the
young have a flourishing pop culture
i don't think that's
true i think what's more happening is
that
both um the boomers and the millennials
slash gen z slash you know wokies or
whatever
they've adopted a spotify pick and mix
attitude towards their playlists and so
you know when i was a teenager
i would listen to top of the pops on the
radio and i'd press play on a cassette
to tape the song i wanted to listen to
again i mean now everybody has all music
that has ever been written at the touch
of a of an ipad an ipad or or an iphone
or a computer you know that you pay a
certain amount a month or you pay
nothing at all
and you have the entire smorgasbord of
world music going back
till the dawn of time recorded music
at your disposal so i think that in a
way we've seen a
melding and a medley effect between the
generations and you saw kids singing
along to the beatles songs
kids sing along to the rolling stones
and oldsters ditto singing along to bad
guy by billy elish
well do you think it's slightly uh
cringe to use a young people's word to
have all this it's cringe to say
dancing is painful enough for young
people when you watch old people well
those who don't have the magical
properties of mick jagger uh dancing it
it can be quite embarrassing
um shouldn't old people just sort of
leave it alone and and age a bit more
gracefully
uh
well you know dad dancing dad jeans mum
dancing all of that
i mean i think there's a place for it
mainly uh as a comedic uh sideshow
mick jagger things
yeah weddings exactly bar and bat
mitzvahs
um to entertain to to embarrass your
children basically
i mean my my children literally have
always screamed and
burst into tears whenever i wiggle my
hips
and
you know i don't care i i am always the
first on to the dance floor i'm always
the last to leave the dance floor it may
be murder on the dance floor or say
fielder's baxter sang but i don't care
it's my party you know and
i love seeing old people dancing it's
funny it's like seeing policemen dancing
at nottingham carnival
i got the impression that that while you
obviously were thrilled by mick jagger
uh
you said you would
uh whatever that means uh but you
weren't quite so um excited by elton
john's performance you thought he did
look a bit doddery
elton john is an amazing voice for her
75 year old
and for a 75 year old who's in the
middle of a
a world tour that seems to have gone on
then longer than
i've been alive i mean i think i saw his
232nd or third gig in the farewell
yellow brick top road tour i think he's
just going to carry on touring forever
you know there's never going to be a
last act for elton john
but having said that i have to say that
both those concerts i attended
at hyde park they did that brilliant
thing of of
no of putting the
audience first you know it may have been
his 232nd
gig but it felt like my first and that's
all that's all you need to deliver as an
artist honestly he really gave it his
all
um and you know how can you how can i
quibble i couldn't actually choose
between the two concerts and i'd like to
just give a shout out to the lighting
designer
another person my age
called patrick woodruff and that really
helps the word the staging you saw that
at paul mccartney in glastonbury people
were saying was that the best gig ever
it wasn't the fact that he was sitting
there in pretty good voice himself it
was the whole miserable sam that they
now do the fireworks the lighting
the backdrop that shows you know elf you
know john lennon or
george harrison they the lighting design
and the back stage design brings so much
to a concert now you feel you're you're
sort of it's an immersive experience
and that also
totally wows the crowd as well because
there's so much to look at most of the
time people are up there with their
mobile phones filming it and going home
and watching it afterwards
finally rachel do you think
that your grandchildren
will watch billy eilish an octogenarian
billy eilish
on the stage in 60 years time at some
festival
that's an incredibly good question and i
think my instinct is
the usp of billy eilish is her youth the
fact that she wrote her tracks with her
brother in their bedroom uh when they
were being homeschooled in california
and she speaks for that you know
pandemic generation of kids who just
grew up online
um who you know quite an isolated
experience you didn't even go to school
and then there was the pandemic and i
think she speaks for that generation i'm
not sure she's going to speak for
eight subsequent
decades in the same way i think she's
having her time now
thank you rachel keep on rocking in the
free world
you make my rocking world go round
freddy
thank you
thank you very very much for watching uh
spectator tv that's it for this week um
if you want to keep watching if you want
to watch this again
don't forget to click that red button at
the bottom of your screen and tap the
bell icon and you will never ever miss
an episode thanks very much goodbye
[Music]
you